on this story itself about these two
companies seeking a truce I mean is this
just the fact that is costing more and
more money to get faster and faster
absolutely it's it's an arms race you
mentioned it and nobody wins an arms
race in the end no one ever has and
what's happening is that the the revenue
associated with these smaller gains that
they're making in speed it's not enough
to cover the costs that are up there so
you're having problems some feelings are
going out of business some are trying to
consolidate but every here's the problem
with some of the hfc community is that
once one person decides I'm going to
jump on that line I'm going to get a new
microwave network I'm going to put
lasers on top of a building what
everybody else had to do that everyone
else has to do it otherwise there's my
advantage so you that is that's what
definition of an arms race and it's
still going on there's no doubt about it
so even though there was a little
consolidation there's a lot of still a
lot of spending going on well so what
does that mean for the structure of the
market than Joe well the problem that we
have is people have called us high
frequency trading critics and to an
extent we are but we're really market
structure critics and the problem is the
structure has changed to allow it's been
a fragmented market for years they've
got 11 stock exchanges over 40 dark
pools and to connect those that's where
the speed advantages come into play
that's why all the money is being any
more and more distorted as it's been
distorted they've kind of glued it back
together with all these high-speed
connections but our point has always
been that's not real liquidity that's
fragmented liquidity we'd rather
aggregate it and you don't need 11 don't
you know exchanges in 40 door pools and
even the high frequency traders will say
you know it's too many because they now
have to pay to connect not only for the
for the hardware but actually to the
exchanges they have to pay a lot of
money for lines and so on so yeah it's
cost prohibitive for them as well so
Michael Lewis has an answer and because
he's making the rounds on this one year
anniversary of his book Joe his answer
is to slow everything down I want you to
hear what he said about that if every
exchange took the response every market
took the responsibility to make itself
fair by eliminating the speed advantages
that they said but then the problem to
go away the problem is the exchange is
sell the speed to the trader so it's a
big source of revenue for the exchanges
so it would be a collapse of their
business model and to do this listen at
we love we love Michael Lewis head if we
love the book
your book and we appreciate that any
time I can get a shout out for Michael
Ellis will take it but it's really you
can't regulate speed and we would never
come in and say technologically we want
to slow things down that's not the
writing I don't want to do that what I
want to do is have a fair market where
he's right and that certain exchanges
are selling privileges well that's where
we have to talk about it there's
something called a sip which everyone
knows about now I have to add versus
with your direct feeds that exchanges or
so those don't match how can you ever
get them to match you really can't so
you what you can try to do is speed that
sip up as much and that's where the
exchanges like Nasdaq who runs the SIP
have to spend some more money and trying
to do that but it really is difficult so
one of the solutions have been like I X
has done is to slow down their market to
try to match up those speeds to an
extent that's worked so what's the
problem so there's lots of rigging
clinical rigging going on right now so
like last week we were at the futures
industry association conference we
talked to Tim acid of the CFTC asked him
about spoofing okay so that's all is
that the latest thing spoofy spoof has
been going on as long as markets have
been here but the problem now is that
you have high-speed electronics where
there are pretty much they're not
obligated market makers anymore they're
not they're just a bunch of prop traders
the case is that the SEC have been
bringing then the SEC has actually made
and the CFTC's been getting a lot
tougher on this it's prop traders who
are out there layering the book and
putting in fake quote bids and offers to
try to get someone else to react and
that's illegal and it should be dealt
with in the CFTC actually has a lot more
power than the SEC on that but the
problem is it's it's the high speed and
a lot of the Union does the SEC have
enough technology to catch it all right
enough people